this place is heated entirely by the
heat produced by Bitcoin miners and this
generates enough heat for the 14,000
square feet of the embassy to get heated
there's a lot of things that go on in
the Bitcoin embassy it's three floors so
each floor has a different different
purpose we have a co-working space where
people who are working on Bitcoin
related projects or other cryptocurrency
or distributed systems there's also a
Bitcoin ATM in the embassy where people
obviously buy bitcoins on the first
floor there's also a trading desk where
people can come and buy and sell
bitcoins as well we organised Bitcoin
meetups for beginners and also for
advanced we give out formations on how
to use Bitcoin installed the coin
wallets etc it's very difficult for for
Bitcoin businesses to be banked in
Canada so while the the day to day
consumer and merchants about production
of Bitcoin might not be as high as in
the US I would say that per capita we
have more VC investment we have more
ATMs more VidCon advocacy groups so it's
different dynamics the Canadian Senate
was one of the first parliamentary body
in the world to engage Bitcoin first and
foremost by gathering expertise and
knowledge through a an official study by
a parliamentary committee and it seems
like they were they were quite favorable
to Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies the way
that we approached them was by showing
them the potential that Bitcoin has for
innovation and specifically you know
innovation means new services new
platforms these services and platforms
are operated and created and maintained
by people who are paid salaries who pay
taxes so there is a definite economic
potential for for Canada the concept of
opting out is is is almost romantic
so participating in the Bitcoin economy
itself is really rewarding but it's also
it also puts a huge competitive pressure
on governments for example to manage
their money supply more responsibly now
you have
real legitimate competitor to that money
which was not the case before so
pursuing and helping bitcoin is is a way
to in fact not only create your own
society but to change the global society